interesting to me that Amazon sort of
had some awards success because we have
no idea how the business is doing of
streaming this content yeah I think this
was huge for Amazon that get so much
attention at the Golden Globes and
certainly transparent getting the win in
that category was very big and obviously
you know having Jeffrey Tambor who's an
incredible actor Jill Soloway the
producer who worked on a series called
Six Feet Under for HBO several years ago
I mean they're bringing a lot to the
table and I think talent is becoming
very agnostic in terms of the platforms
on which they will share their wares so
to speak and for Woody Allen what it you
know he's an icon a huge name and for
Amazon de packed with Woody Allen is a
big deal and that raises awareness for
Amazon in a major way this is an iconic
director known obviously for his filmed
work on the big screen certainly his
movies have done very well on the small
screen as well and this is just a great
move by amazon the awareness windows are
through the roof right now I wonder if
it's something else actually I wonder if
you know Woody Allen sort of the classic
case of a director whose work some
people like and most people don't right
some people even live and most people
don't and I wonder if this is proof that
there's room in this new distribution
strategy for the long tail for the
things that some people will love and
most people won't but the economy is
there now are the economics are there
now when they weren't you know they had
just a few channels in which to watch
things and a few ways to pay for them
that's a great point and that's true
Woody Allen is your right and he's very
polarizing for a lot of different
reasons both in front of the camera and
behind the camera and in his personal
life but no question that platforms like
Amazon can take a chance by putting
Woody Allen in charge of a TV show
something's really never done before and
they have the bandwidth they have the
the breadth of audience where this just
brings attention to them which i think
is part of bringing attention
their roster so to speak and if you look
at for instance Netflix with orange is
the new black and house of cards n HBO
with their original series I mean the
fact that these various entities have
the resources and now have the bench so
to speak of talent to create this
original content which is getting
noticed obviously by the critical side
of things the critical community with
awards and such this is to me for Amazon
a great step towards building that
roster of having great actors writers
directors producers and the name Woody
Allen would you like them or you don't
like him he's a big name and everyone
knows who he is and this brings a
heightened awareness of Amazon